THE LATEST LEGAL RESPONSE TO THE
RAID IS GOING ON THE OFFENSE.
HERE NOW IS HARMEET DHILLON,
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
HARMEET, YOU SAY THIS IS A START
BUT IT NEEDS TO BE ONE OF MANY
SUCH MOTIONS TO KEEP UP THIS
MOMENTUM.
EXPLAIN.
>> THANK YOU, LAURA.
TWO WEEKS AGO, THERE WAS AN
UNPRECEDENTED RATE ON THE
PRESIDENT'S HOME, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S HOME.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
ASKED FOR IS THE APPOINTMENT OF
A SPECIAL MASTERS OF OUTBACK
THAT NORMALLY WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
AN EXECUTION OF A SEARCH WARRANT
LIKE THIS, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ASSIGNS A SEPARATE TEAM
OF PROSECUTORS TO LOOK OVER
THOSE MATERIALS TO SUSS OUT
ANYTHING THAT'S PRIVILEGED OR
OTHERWISE SHOULD NOT BE SEEN BY
THE MAIN PROSECUTOR.
IN THE TIME THAT IT'S TAKEN TO
GET TO THIS POINT, IT MAY
ALREADY BE THE CASE WITH THAT
THAT YOU DOJ HAS ALREADY DONE
THAT.
IF YOU TRUST THEM, THE DOJ
PROSECUTORS ASSIGNED ON EITHER
SIDE TO DO THE RIGHT THING THEN
NO PROBLEM BUT IF YOU DON'T
TRUST THEM THAN THE SORT OF
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL MASTER
IS AN INDEPENDENT LAWYER, FORMER
JUDGE OR WHAT HAVE YOU, TO
OVERSEE THE PROCESS
INDEPENDENTLY, THAT SHOULD
ALREADY HAVE BEEN DONE.
I HOPE IT ISN'T TOO LATE FOR
THAT PARTICULAR MOTION.
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT NEED TO
BE CONSIDERED ARE, IS THIS
JUDGE, THE JUDGE BRUCE
REINHARDT, CLEARLY SHOWED
HIMSELF TO BE BIASED, IS HE THE
CORRECT PERSON TO BE RULING ON
THESE ISSUES?
SHOULD THERE BE MOTION TO RECUSE
THAT JUDGE?
IT'S RISKY TO CLOUD SUCH A
MOTION.
THERE IS MENTION IN THIS FILING
TODAY A RETURN OF PROPERTY.
I THINK MAY BE THAT TRUMP TEAM
IS WAITING FOR THE RULINGS ON
THURSDAY AFTER JUDGE REINHARDT
LOOKS AT THE REDACTION REQUEST
AND OTHER ISSUES TO SEE ABOUT
THAT AND GET MORE DIRECTION ON
THAT.
I THINK THIS IS JUST THE FIRST
STEP.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A VERY
AGGRESSIVE RESPONSE TO THIS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT IS ABOUT THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT, IT'S ABOUT THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
IT'S ABOUT WHETHER THE ESPIONAGE
ACT SHOULD APPLY AT ALL TO A
FORMER RESIDENT UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO FOR ALL THESE REASONS IT'S
DEEPLY TROUBLING AND I'M GLAD TO
SEE THEM TAKE THIS FOR STEPHANIE
TO BE A LOT MORE.
>> Laura: LIKE CLOCKWORK WE
KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TONIGHT GOT
A LEAK FROM THE FEDS SANG TRUMP
IN MORE THAN THREE AND/OR
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO AMONG THE ITEMS THEY
KNEW WERE MISSING WERE
MR. TRUMP'S ORIGINAL LETTERS
FROM THE NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR
KIM JONG UN.
NOTES THAT
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA HAD LEFT
FROM BEFORE HE LEFT OFFICE.
IT GOES ON AND ON.
THEY SOURCE PEOPLE WITH
FAMILIARITY WITH THE CASE.
WHETHER IT'S THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES FOLKS WERE THEM,
CONVERSATIONS WITH DOJ, SOMEBODY
GAVE THAT INFORMATION TO MAGGIE
HABERMAN.
SHE IS A GOOD REPORTER.
SHE TAKES IT AND RUNS WITH IT.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED IN RUSSIA
GATE, IS IT NOT?
DRIP, DRIP, DRIP.
>> THE FACT THAT THIS IS HOW THE
UNITED STATES PERMANENT JUST
DISPLAYS ITS GAME.
SHOULD BE FRONT AND CENTER IN A
MOTION ABOUT A SPECIAL MASTER.
THAT TYPE OF SHENANIGAN IS
EXACTLY WHAT GOT A SPECIAL
MASTER APPOINTED IN THE PROJECT
VERITAS CASE.
READING AMERICAN JOURNALISTS ON
A FLIMSY PRETEXT.
HERE, SIMILARLY, I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE USED ON
THE OFFENSE.
IT'S IMPROPER FOR THE DOJ TO USE
THE PRESS IN THIS MANNER.
EVEN AFTER YOU SET ASIDE THE
HYPE IN THE ARTICLE AND TAKE AT
FACE VALUE.
SO WHAT.
WE LEARNED DURING THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL SCANDAL
THAT OVER CLASSIFICATION IS
RAMPANT.
HILLARY CLINTON WASN'T EVEN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
IT STILL IS NOT AN EXCUSE 18
MONTHS AFTER THIS PERSON IS LEFT
OFFICE TO RATE HIS HOME IN ONE
OF THE GOOD THINGS THAT THE
MOTION DOES THIS TO TELL THE
STORY OF HOW PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
TEAM WAS COOPERATING ALL ALONG.
IT WAS HIS OWN HOUSE.
HE PUT IN EXTRA LAW.
THEN THERE ARE FBI AGENTS.
>> Laura: LET ME JUMP IN.
NO THE SCUTTLEBUTT IS ABOUT WHEN
ARE WE GOING TO GET THE INTERNAL
SURVEILLANCE VIDEO OF THE
STORAGE ROOM.
THERE'S ANOTHER STORAGE ROOM.
THIS REMINDS ME OF WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
TO KEEP THE NARRATIVE GOING.
THEY HAVE TO DO THIS.
>> IT IS THE SAME PLAYBOOK.
WE HAVE SEEN IT FROM DAY ONE.
AS A NETWORK.
THERE IS CORRUPT SYMBIOTIC
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND THE PEOPLE
WHO CONTROL THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE THE CASE FOR
ANY AMERICAN.
THIS IS HOW THEY PLAY IT AT
EVERY LEVEL AND IT NEEDS TO
STOP.
IF MERRICK GARLAND HAVE ANY
INTEGRITY, HE WOULD BE COMING
OUT AND HOLDING A PRESS
CONFERENCE RIGHT NOW TALKING
ABOUT THE OUTRAGEOUS BEHAVIOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THE INVESTIGATION THAT HE'S
GOING TO ASK TO BE HOWLED INTO
THESE LEAKS IN THE VIOLATIONS OF
DOJ POLICY.
YOU DON'T SEE THEM DOING THAT
BECAUSE IT'S A FEATURE NOT A BUG
OF THE SYSTEM.
>> Laura: I LOVE THAT LINE.
WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT WHO
LEAK THAT INFORMATION TO MAGGIE
HABERMAN.
WE ARE GOING TO FIND A WHO LEADS
THE DRAFT OPINION IN THE DOBBS
CASE.
I'M NOT HOLDING MY BREATH ON